the name lucifer is one that conjures
many different images the most common
being that of satan or the devil
an angel who fell from grace and
rebelled against god
a figure who exists to tempt man and
woman into sin
a universal idea that can be seen in
numerous religions and beliefs
but in terms of demonology lucifer
represents one of the seven deadly sins
the sin of pride
so
oh
[Music]
the book of revelations describes a war
that took place in heaven between the
angels those who lost would be cast from
heaven and left to inhabit to the earth
then war broke out in heaven
michael and his angels fought against
the dragon and the dragon and his angels
fought back
but he was not strong enough and they
lost their place in heaven the great
dragon was hurled down
that ancient serpent called the devil or
satan who leads the world astray
he was hurled down to earth and his
angels with him
this story has been interpreted in
several ways
some believe this dragon refers to
lucifer the most beautiful of god's
angels
but with this came an immense amount of
pride and lucifer soon began to question
his creator and everything around him
he considered himself different from the
other angels he refused to accept the
universe in its current state and as his
paranoia grew he believed god himself
was flawed and that he was the only
perfect being left
in his doubt of god he wasn't alone as
he managed to convince a third of the
angels in heaven to join his cause
the first action against god was
directed at his prized creation
humankind god's interest in humans is
something that lucifer could never
understand to him they were extremely
flawed beings and he would never bow
down to such an inferior creation
he convinced the archangel samael to
take the form of a serpent and tempt eve
into taking the forbidden fruit causing
both adam and eve to be cast from the
garden of eden
he then convinced a third of the angels
in heaven to side with him in this
rebellion against god and when the time
for war came he transformed himself into
a great dragon
on one side stood lucifer and the angels
who wanted change
on the other side stood a much larger
army led by the archangel michael
this war would rage on for many years
but eventually michael and the angels
who sided with him and god would emerge
of victors and lucifer this great dragon
was cast from heaven and all those who
aligned with him would suffer the same
fall from grace
there is also a telling of this story
where lucifer is cast from heaven and
seeks revenge against god
with the creation of adam and eve
lucifer was no longer god's favorite
being so what better revenge than the
corruption of humankind
when they were created adam and eve were
instructed by god to never eat from the
tree of knowledge lucifer would disguise
himself as a serpent and seduce eve into
taking a bite of the forbidden fruit and
thus they would also be cast from the
garden of eden
the story itself can be quite confusing
because some believe the serpent may
have been the archangel samael doing the
bidding of satan
others argue the serpent was indeed
lucifer as not only does he take the
form of a dragon but he's also referred
to as that old serpent
it's never explained in any detail so it
just comes down to how you interpret
these scriptures and stories
there are some references that make it
fairly easy to draw this connection
between satan and lucifer in isaiah 14
12-15 it says
how you are fallen from heaven o daystar
son of dawn
how you are cut down to the ground you
who laid the nations low you said in
your heart i will ascend to heaven above
the stars of god i will set my throne on
high i will sit on the mount of assembly
in the far reaches of the north i will
ascend above the heights of clouds i
will make myself like the most high
but you are brought down to shield to
the far reaches of the pit
in hebrew the king of babylon is
condemned in a vision by the prophet
isaiah and is called halil ben shahar
which means the son of morning or
shining one
this was then translated by the greeks
and romans to mean morning star or light
bringer and this king would then become
lucifer
this passage in isaiah can therefore be
seen as detailing the fall of lucifer
from heaven how he aimed to place
himself above god and take the throne
for himself but instead ended up in hell
ezekiel 28 17 also mentions this fall
from grace
your heart was proud because of your
beauty you corrupted your wisdom for the
sake of your splendor
i cast you to the ground i exposed you
before kings to feast their eyes on you
these passages show lucifer as the
fallen angel
it isn't until the account of the war in
heaven in the book of revelations we
mentioned earlier that this fall belongs
to satan
and he said to them my source satan fall
like lightning from heaven
no mention of the morning star or a
fallen angel it's satan or in
revelations a dragon
with this transformation obviously comes
a change in appearance
lucifer the morning star the most
beautiful of god's creations would have
been a radiant being
but with this fall from grace and
demonization lucifer would look more
satanic
his once beautiful feathered wings would
be more webbed like that of a bat
his face was warped and twisted and on
top of his head sat horns
what was once a thing of beauty then
became a thing of terror with images of
satan not even resembling a human form
more so a demonic goat man with wings
with this transformation into satan also
came the association with evil warlocks
and witches
peter binsfield identified seven demons
that were classified as the princes of
hell
all of them associated with one of the
seven deadly sins
lucifer of course represented the sin of
pride dante's inferno does also have an
interesting take on satan which i won't
go into too much detail about because
the patrons have decided it's a video
i'll be making very soon
dante satan is an enormous demon with
bat-like wings and three faces who is
frozen in ice at the very center of hell
he also makes it known that satan was
once an angel of light known as lucifer
where dante differs from the other
authors is in the way he portrays satan
as grotesque motionless and unable to
speak a giant slobbering mass
he isn't the ruler of hell he resides
there as a prisoner and receives the
same punishment as all other sinners
which is very different to the lucifer
we see in the next piece of literature
the book of revelations doesn't directly
tell you that lucifer and satan are the
same entity but this connection between
lucifer and satan is one that authors
and historians have embellished and
developed over the years
one of the most famous examples of this
would be john milton's epic poem
paradise lost this narrative follows the
fall of mankind and one particular angel
milton satan was lucifer one of the most
beautiful angels in heaven he refused to
answer to the will of god because angels
were born and raised themselves they had
no mother and no father so why should
god have authority over them it's better
to reign in hell than serve in heaven
milton's character is both cunning and
charismatic
although lucifer and his followers lost
this war and were cast from heaven he
was still able to obtain the power he
desired as he would reign in hell with
those who sided with him
milton in a way paints lucifer in a
heroic manner and you could argue this
is because he represented milton's own
beliefs
it's no secret he wasn't the biggest fan
of the king of england and believed he
should be overthrown as he felt a
parliament would be much more
representative of the people
lucifer isn't too different from milton
believing that the angels should govern
themselves instead of answering to god
in paradise lost milton frames god as a
tyrannical leader and those opposed to
him suffer his wrath not too different
to how he viewed the king of england
lucifer for example lost to everything
at first glance he lost his beauty his
status in heaven and he was no longer
god's favorite creation
and yet we still see this idea that it's
better to rule in hell than to live in
heaven under tyranny
the war in heaven was lost but lucifer
still achieved his goal
although it's very common to look at
satan as pure evil lucifer on the other
hand presents us with a much more
relatable and interesting character
we see that today often in modern
fiction he's by no means a beacon of
light or even a hero but there is a
strange fascination with his story
if we break down the fall of lucifer
most of it does stem from curiosity
wanting to question the state of the
universe and not simply accept the rules
that have been laid out before him by
someone else
if you follow the biblical scriptures
then lucifer's pride is the sin that
leads to evil and his downfall however
if you approach the story in a less
biblical fashion as milton does in
paradise lost it's essentially lucifer
asking a series of questions about the
world he lives in and deciding he
doesn't want to be governed by someone
else he doesn't believe represents him
or the other angels
you could argue that's because the
motives behind these stories are not the
same
the biblical stories are a warning for
those who wish to challenge the word of
god for their own gain demonizing those
who do milton's work on the other hand
is an invitation to challenge a
tyrannical rule or status quo if it
doesn't represent you or the people
around you lucifer is certainly an
interesting figure whether you feel like
you can understand the reasoning behind
his actions or simply believe that he is
the devil
works like paradise lost and even the
more recent lucifer tv show at least ask
the question
is he really that evil
the answer lies with you
but i'm sure some of you will let me
know
as always i've been your host
mythology infection explained
[Music]
[Music]
you